alors pour introduire le prochain
intervenant je vais vous dire une date
et j'espère qu'elle vous parle à toutes
et tous cette date c'est le 22 février
c'était un jour de bascule un jour qui a
permis l'élection du président de la
république en 2017 quand vous monsieur
françois bayrou avait annoncé votre
soutien à emmanuel macron
fondateur du modem aujourd'hui en
commissaire au plan
artisan de cette grande maison commune
combattit ensemble je vous demande un
tonnerre d'applaudissements pour
françois bayrou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'organisateur est venu me voir pour
dire on a pris du retard est-ce qu'il
est imaginable que vous le fassiez dans
les quinze minutes quand vous offre j'ai
dit oui et je n'ai qu'une parole
et donc je vous promets d'être
respectueux je voudrais commencer par
une note un peu plus triste
parce que tant que nous sommes réunis
dans cette ambiance si chaleureuse
beaucoup de français ont une et prouve
une grande émotion parce que bernard
tapie vient de mourir
alors je voudrais
je crois être à peu près le mieux
qualifié
pour parler de lui en deux phrases
parce que j'ai été avec lui dans une
opposition
extrêmement
engagée et puis un jour par un de ces
événements
que quelquefois
la vie apporte sans qu'on sache très
bien pourquoi
ça s'est renversée et par un coup de
théâtre
amical nous nous sommes rencontrés
retrouvés et on a beaucoup parlé
ensemble
je voudrais simplement
dire pourquoi je crois les français
étaient sli attaché
entraîné par son par sa figure je pense
que c'était une immense énergie
et c'était une immense énergie qui ne
abandonnait jamais qu'ils ne se
rendaient jamais
qui continuer à porter le combat quelles
que fussent les événements et les chocs
et deux cela de cette énergie là et
aussi de cette fidélité fidélité
aux siens à sa famille à marseille
au football à l'aventuré à toutes les
aventures je suis sûr que beaucoup de
français par cet engagement était ému et
je voulais devant vous simplement dire
que beaucoup d'entre nous aussi on en
tête cette incroyable aventure humaine
au moment où bernard tapie
sereinement paisiblement comme ses
enfants et dominique sa femme blonde y
vient de nous quitter
nous vivons un moment
crucial
où tout va se jouer
probablement aucune élection
présidentielle
n'a eu autant d'importance
n'a engagé autant le destin de son pays
que celle qui va avoir lieu dans
quelques mois
cette élection présidentielle elle
intervient dans un moment de profond
bouleversement
de
la planète
profonds bouleversements parce que le
changement climatique touche la totalité
de l'humanité si nous n'y réfléchissons
que du point de vue de notre hexagone on
passerait complètement à côté des enjeux
immenses qui sont là devant nous
immense enjeu pour la planète parce que
une dérive des continents comme on dit
est en cours et cette dérive des
continents il faut pas se tromper ce
qu'elle met en jeu
c'est l'idée que nous nous faisons de
notre destin collectif ce qu'elle met en
jeu faut le dire comme c'est c'est
l'idée que la démocratie et l'avenir des
peuples il n'est pas certain aujourd'hui
qu'il y ait sur la planète une majorité
pour partager encore cette conviction la
immense enjeu est au coeur de cet enjeu
il y à l'europe l'idée qu'elle se fait
de son avenir est au coeur de l'europe
il ya la france qui va dire en élisant
le président de la république quelle est
sa vision de son avenir et du destin
est immense enjeu aussi moment crucial
parce que ce qui est en train de se
réveiller dans nos sociétés
ce que certains veulent réveiller
savamment
ce sont des remugles
des
mouvements profonds qu'on croyait
disparue depuis longtemps je vous
appelle sans en dire plus à relire ce
qui se disait en france dans les années
en ciblant un certain nombre de
catégories de français
en raison
de leur origine
en raison de leurs différences
en raison par exemple de leur engagement
philosophique
ça passe inaperçu
mais si vous lisez vous allez voir ce
qui se passe
ce conte ce qui se trame
dans une espèce d'indifférence générale
pas chez nous
comme si
beaucoup de responsables étaient non pas
des acteurs mais dû semer des
spectateurs de ce qui se joue est notre
fierté et non pas d'être spectateur et
d'accepter mais d'être acteur et de
résister
[Applaudissements]
dans ce paysage là nous avons tous
ensemble une responsabilité
et c'est une responsabilité qui nous
oblige à nous mettre en question nous
mêmes et à nous engager nous mêmes on a
fait beaucoup vous avez rappelé après à
très juste titre
ce qui s'est passé au mois de février il
ya cinq ans et la rencontre de ces
courants qui a en effet changé le
rapport de forces est donc le destin du
pays mais
ce que ce qui est frappant aujourd'hui
c'est que
alors que tout le monde prédisait le
contraire pendant ces cinq années ces
mouvements différents
non pas différent par l'idée
qu'ils se font du pays ou de la
citoyenneté ou de l'avenir mais
différents par leur histoire par le
chemin parcouru d'où ils viennent et
nous avons en effet des sensibilités et
des chemins différents mais ces deux
mouvements pendant cinq ans ils n'ont
pas eu entre eux une seule lézarde je
veux le dire devant les responsables des
groupes parlementaires
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas eu un affrontement sur le
fond
richard tu as dit d agacement à peine d
agacement des ridules à la surface de
l'eau
dont je ne vise personne mais que vous
voyez bien que sur le fond nous avons
défendu les mêmes positions et quand il
y avait des débats c'était des débats
internes autant que des débats entre
nous des débats internes à chaque
formation autant que des questions qui
se posaient à
entre les formations donc c'est un très
beau travail je n'ai pas souvenir faut
quand même qu'on se le dise entre nous
je n'ai pas souvenir d'une majorité qui
es tu aussi peu de problèmes aussi peu
de différences aussi peu d'affrontements
aussi peu de chicaya que la majorité que
nous avons construite et conduite
ensemble depuis 2017
mais nous avons une responsabilité pour
l'avenir
c'est de mesurer
la désaffection de l'engagement dans
notre pays
tout à l'heure et à très juste titre on
a défendu
l'engagement politique gérald darmanin a
dit que qu'il trouvait ça comme moi je
je pense le plus au fond le loch une des
plus belles manières de donner sens à sa
vie que de se sentir responsable du
destin commun c'est très
c'est très important c'est très
valorisant
mais convenons-en ensemble une très
grande partie de nos concitoyens ne s'y
reconnaît plus
je pense que jamais dans l'histoire
nous n'avons lui aussi peu d'adhérents
formations politiques et de militants
des formations politiques
depuis un siècle que ces derniers mois
ou ces dernières années les partis
politiques sont en déshérence
alors je veux risquer une explication
avec vous qui devrait nous permettre de
tracer un chemin je pense que les partis
politiques sont en déshérence pour deux
raisons la première c'est que les
citoyens les électeurs ont peur de se
trouver enrégimentés s'il entre s'il
adhère dans une formation politique
il nous revient donc de rendre
conciliables
l'engagement et la liberté et c'est une
très importante
la liberté du débat la liberté de
l'énergie la liberté de la controverse
s'il y en a
mais l'engagement et la solidarité c'est
la première raison la deuxième raison
c'est je crois que c'est les débats
internes aux formations politiques sont
devenus du chinois pour la plupart des
français
les guerres de chapelle à chapelle les
guerres de clans à klan les guerres
d'ego à ego sont le plus effroyable
répulsif que la politique puisse offrir
il nous revient donc de concilier la
liberté et l'unité
[Applaudissements]
et comme je ne crois qu'au fond des
choses moi je regarde je scrute
j'observe j'analyse depuis cinq ans en
réalité nos raison d'engagements ce sont
les mêmes
il n'y a pas un engagement en marche il
est plus récent il est très
porté par la figure des manuels mâcon
mais sur la philosophie des choses sur
la manière dont on regarde l'avenir sur
ce qu'on appelle doctrine et idéologies
philosophie politique en réalité vous le
sentez bien depuis que nous sommes
ensemble depuis cinq ans et depuis 5
heures
c'est laid ce sont les mêmes raisons de
vivre qui ne vous pousse qui nous pousse
tous ensemble à être engagés et à être
là il faut en tirer les conclusions je
pense que le destin qui est devant nous
c'est de rapprocher de rassembler d'unir
d'unifier les forces politiques qui font
partie aujourd'hui de cette majorité
[Applaudissements]
et en commençant bien entendu par en
marche et le modem j'ai été très ému
tout au long des deux heures que nous
avons passés avant ce 7e rencontre par
le nombre de ceux qui sont venus me voir
en disant ah j'ai commencé au modem je
m'étais éloigné et puis je suis revenu
par en marche qu'est-ce que je suis
content contente que nous soyons
ensemble et ceci est pour moi une
certitude
pas seulement un plaisir ou une
disposition positive pour l'avenir mais
une certitude c'est que cette
unification
c'est notre devoir dans le moment et
dans le monde où nous sommes
[Applaudissements]
alors je suis d'accord par définition
avec richard ferrand
je suis d'accord par définition avec
stan guérini je suis persuadé que nous
rencontrons par définition les désirs
secrets du premier ministre
on doit faire ça avant noël
[Applaudissements]
et faire ça ça veut dire une chose
simple c'est garantir à chacun de ceux
qui participeront la pleine
reconnaissance
de ces droits de ses devoirs de son
patrimoine de sa mémoire de ces acquis
avec une règle que je voudrais énoncé
devant vous c'est que
ce que nous allons dessiner ensemble
comme règle du jeu ça doit nous obliger
à travailler ensemble et nous empêcher
de nous disputer les uns contre les
autres
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais finir
pour respecté à la seconde le temps de
parole qui m'a été imparti je voudrais
finir avant vous rapporte en une phrase
que jacques séguéla a dit et qui je
crois une des plus justes à propos de la
campagne présidentielle qu'on puisse
dire jacques séguéla a dit on ne vote
pas pour un programme
on vote pour une idée c'est à dire une
représentation de l'avenir
mobilisatrice un idéal
et on ne vote pas pour une idée on vote
pour une personne
et je voudrais vous dire ceci
l'enjeu qui est devant nous la
responsabilité qui est la nôtre
c'est de montrer à nos concitoyens
la personne du candidat le jour où il
décidera s'il se décide je prends toutes
les précautions de langage nécessaire
comme vous le voyez mais
en quoi la personne
cette incroyable aventure humaine
qui a fait la vie le destin du président
de la république emmanuel macron en quoi
cette personne est en phase et je crois
que beaucoup ne savent pas encore où un
nom douter en doute un peu moins parce
que depuis l'épidémie est depuis la
pandémie ont vu quelle était la nature
protectrice du président de la
république mais je veux et il faut que
nous montrions quelle est
la proximité immédiate
qui est celle de d'emmanuel macron
président de la république avec ceux de
nos concitoyens qui
rencontrent le plus de difficultés
qui ont le plus de mal à vivre et que
nous sommes plusieurs ici à avoir
éprouvé cent fois dans les déplacements
qui sont les siens je veux dire
il ya une chose que je te hais je fais
pas profession de flagornerie en général
c'est plutôt sur l'autre pente je veux
dire une chose ce que je trouve le plus
émouvant chez lui c'est j'allais dire
l'obsession en tout cas là la ligne
directrice de ne plus jamais laisser les
jeunes en particulier
être bloqué attaché au destin qui leur
était promis quand ils sont mais parce
qu'ils sont pas du même milieu parce
qu'ils sont par les chances culturel ou
économique
ce que
[Musique]
ce que vous avez appelé
l'assignation à résidence
qui est totalement juste un peu
difficile à comprendre
le fait qu'on soit condamné à ne pas
pouvoir être autre chose que ce que
commande le milieu dans lequel on est né
ceci c'est notre combat et c'est
l'article 1 du contrat social que nous
avons a renouvelé entre les français et
le destin politique du pays l'article 1
du contrat social c'est que nous sommes
là pour émanciper pour libérer pour
donner à chacun d'où qu'ils viennent les
chances qu autrement il n'aurait pas eu
c'est cette révolution là
où tout va se jouer
et je trouve que sept
une immense chance que de pouvoir
défendre un destin est un idéal autour
de la figure d'un homme qui mérite notre
engagement merci à tous
[Applaudissements]